all right gomo welcome back and thank
you mark it's been a while it has
so there were so many questions left
unanswered last time we did this
that i'd love to know i think a lot of
people would like to know
i think let's just start with some
questions and we'll go from there sure
what uh how vulnerable are we all to
people like yourself to a hacker
uh the average person is exceptionally
vulnerable to any sorts of intrusions
whether they be digital or in real life
the trails that we leave behind are the
narrative that spreads within right we
leave
we leave everyone leaves trails on
social media platforms
with purchases
with any type of
interaction in their daily life such as
when you drive in a car
there
you may or may not realize it but
your license plate is being captured
with a r
and
at that point that data is fed into
public systems
and
you are able to be identified rather
quickly with someone with
mild potential and a little bit of
python programming language
how is your license plate being picked
up
um mostly through municipalities where
they are capturing your license plate as
they go through
state pass systems um easy pass sun
paths etc and so
those systems also share with the public
scope
your license plate and of course there's
dot cameras everywhere so
you really
all you really must must remember is
that
someone with a little bit of ingenuity
and some
time on their hands can write together a
program
that's able to identify your specific
license plate and then ping you or have
or create an action on that
so it's
that's just one narrative there's so
many um as i mentioned social media
um
that that's that's a terrible place to
[Music]
uh it's a terrible place to
share your life with because you're
who are you sharing your life with uh
would you go out
of your front yard and
say hey put all of your personal photos
in your front yard for your neighbors to
see
but yet most people are doing that on
the the internet on the world wide web
on apps etc and so
that causes a problem
when you are trying to expect some sort
of privacy
away from
digital threats
what's been the most
if you want to do something
really dark and disturbing with with
your skills what what kind of stuff have
you gotten into
um i mean they're
you could you could do something in the
name of good like with you know trying
to find
sex offenders for example or something
like that you could also do things
against corporations you do all kinds of
stuff right
you can and i have and i'm i'm very well
proud of the things that i've
done in my past
i've
done some things that even
shocked me along the way um
usually you know i i always speak to
people in it with a lot of passion and
telling them to use their skills for
something good because it's so easy to
use your skills in such a nefarious way
in the past for me it was catching
thieves
targeting retail outlets in the tens and
hundreds of millions of dollars to which
those threat actors are in prison still
to this day
um
it's my goal and i've always used my
skills after i was able to identify that
i'm a good guy right
and it's always been my intent to
make sure that people
don't have to wake up with their credit
ruined or their lives
digitally firebombed because
they were just part of something
innocent and
i feel good when i help
situations that um
right those wrongs with my skills
what's behind it for you
what motivated you to even
follow this path is there something in
your personality is it
is it fueled by anger is it fueled by
why are you a hacker basically
um
you know
i just turned 50
and
when i when i was seven and eight years
old
i used to take apart our television set
with a butter knife and
i wanted to know where the pictures came
from and
i wanted to know how it worked i i was
curious as you know like
how does this thing get sound and
yeah i was fascinated with it and so
i could not put the television back
together and my mom warmed my behind for
it but
i never stopped with that um
next up was were the telephones i'm
eight years old and
i'm fascinated with telephones i'm
fascinated with the fact that at eight
years old i'm i'm able to identify
touch tone versus
ringtone and
dtmf versus pulse and
and those systems were fascinating
because
you could
for instance on the old analog systems
you could take a receiver and go click
click click and you could get an
operator right and
well that was cool and so what else can
you do with all of these clicks and
sounds and pops and things and so
um
it was not long before i discovered
phone freaking and by nine years old i'm
freaking telephone systems
the drive is the curiosity um
the
it's the curious nature it's the wonder
of being able to accomplish a task
that's what drives me
the
knowing that i'm helping someone
preventing someone's grandmother from
being a victim of some sort of cyber
extortion scheme
that's the thing that i get up for each
day and those are the things that
motivate me currently today
i
know the dark things that people have
intentions for when it comes to using
information nefariously
and i
do my best to interrupt that
and
i'm going to continue to and i'm not
afraid of anybody
and if
i'm called to take care of that it's
game over for that person or that group
so i'm driven by that is anyone
protected or immune to what you can do
to what i can do it's not polite to brag
but i feel like i'm not limited by any
of my capabilities
but this gets into
there's many different ways of doing
the kind of things that hackers do right
there's many different areas they get
into there are there there are so many
areas of hacking and that's where my
encouragement comes from
it was fascinating last time you talked
about what you did with gas stations
when you were young and broke yeah that
was great
yeah so uh i would take when i was a kid
i was living in uh chevrolet chavez 1989
and
i took a speaker magnet you know and i
broke it off and
the old man at the final station would
he sat in a chair and you would pull up
and you would wave hey and
and you know you had the lever and you
you would take the magnet and stick it
to you know he that's facing the
boulevard and you just stick it here and
you flip the lever and it's gas is
gushing in your
tank but there's the numbers are not
moving and so
and as it comes out you know to accept
payment for your fuel you pull the
magnet off and you just hold it in your
hand like everything's cool and you get
like thirty dollars worth of gas for two
or three dollars
and then today what kind of things are
you getting into they went out of
business no of course yeah but then the
gas pumps have changed since then too
yes but what what kind of things do you
get into nowadays
uh nowadays i
uh i consult
and i um i've joined
uh uh
some ventures to where
i continue to work every day at nine to
five
um bringing my skills to fruition for
the greater good i still threat hunt i
still track down people who need to be
tracked down
and i
even get on zoom calls
i
do what you think i do and what you what
people think i do what i've i've read
the comments i
i
have not looked at that video that i
shot with you a year ago but
before i came here i read the comments
and
the comments were very moving
and that's why
you know people telling me that
you know i helped save them i i
you know they were at the bottom of a
barrel or
they were
they were at their wits in and
they saw my words of encouragement
that's what i do that's why i get up
every morning that's exactly what i do
this for
i make sure that
your mom and grandma and your wife and
husband and kids sleep safe at night
because someone doesn't want them to
sleep safe at night
there's a lot of
a lot of evil in the world isn't there
there sure is and
you must know evil to face it and
i
certainly am not afraid to face any type
of evil mark
has it gotten worse in
the decades you see it has unfortunately
when i was a child it was happy fun
things like sending someone a virus and
opening the cd drawer or
having endless javascript pop-ups that
was fun
but
as with
as with society shifting from an analog
life to a digital life the
the bad things
unfortunately come
along with the with them so instead of
the old days of bonnie and clyde type of
stick ups and banks it's
occurring in
so many channels because those channels
have been opened up for
anyone to
become a criminal if that's their so
desire
the landscape is changed brutally as we
see
software now being creating being being
created
for weaponry
like stuxnet and
wannacry and these types of
systems that are introduced
to create panic and havoc with society
and your iphone
they're continuing to
develop
and increase in
frightening precision
you don't have to look any further than
uh tick-tock
and look at the algorithm on how
frighteningly
accurate is it it is
or when you're speaking around
a bunch of mobile devices ipads whatever
then you start seeing ads for the things
that you were speaking of
that technology is being used to
weaponize
it's being weaponized
to
to be possibly used against people
unknowingly in the future
and so yes
the landscape is growing darker and more
sinister as more people wish to seek
their wealth
[Music]
whether it be cryptocurrency theft or
traditional
[Music]
theft of
banking systems
the
the fact that governments now are keen
to begin a war on on just the idea of
software being deployed is quite
frightening
and unfortunately that will be
society's new reality in the future
how does it make you feel having such an
unusual and powerful skill set
uh you know i
because you could do anything right you
you're wealthy from your
bitcoin
no i'm quite wealthy yeah so you don't
have to work you could be in aruba right
now for
i do not have to work if i don't choose
to i
have over seven billion dollars worth of
bitcoin yes
but you choose to work at nine to five
yeah every day
monday through friday just because
you're doing what you love to do and you
believe in it
i i just explained to your viewers that
that's exactly what motivates me yeah so
how does it make you feel to have this
unusual series of skills
it makes me feel useful to be part of
something bigger when i'm asked to be
part of it
i
i've always
wanted to live a normal life i've always
wanted to
i
like
wonder how
the normal person lives that you know
you get up and you get on the train
right and you go to work in an office in
downtown chicago which i've done which
you know i wanted to i wanted to feel
that i want to feel that and i can't
even even though i've done these things
even though i wrote a train and i hated
it i hate metro in chicago
the
it frightens me i
am reserved i think about things
very cautiously before i speak
and i certainly think four to five times
before i react
yes i i can breach any system or network
whether in real life or digitally and
again it's not me to be here to brag you
ask the questions so
i've
proven myself
i went from a
kid in jacksonville florida being
scrappy picking up coke bottles on fifth
street on the west side
um
to making sure that
i never have to pick up any more goddamn
coke bottles
and i
promised my mom i wouldn't do that
either so
um
these are the things that
keep me in
check making sure that i don't
[ __ ] up
is poverty the
motivator behind a lot of what you're
doing then no it's not poverty was
poverty wasn't anything new to me you
know i
when my daughter was born i was 18 years
old i stood in a food stamp line for two
years every day
you know because
even though i had mentioned
my wife's parents at the time took me in
they never helped my wife or i
for anything
anything
and they haven't spoken to my wife in 10
years
they never did anything for me and so
poverty was common
even her parents set me up to fail
and her my wife
they set us both up to fail every time
that i would accomplish something small
they would
get in the middle of it
so
i choose just to do the right thing
you know
my
wife at the time told me to
[Music]
be
honest and tell the truth and
and and
and do the right thing and
and my best friend who passed away
during the year that i've been on
the soft white underbelly passed away as
well
and
he was
my mentor
and he
would always tell me um he's from the
south side of chicago and
die hard and sox fan and
a irish mobster kind of guy but he would
always tell me
you know he would call me up and say hey
what are you doing i'm like i'm doing
this he's like no no no no no you're
being a [ __ ] jackoff man you're doing
it all wrong and
and i would feel horrible because i'm
like who is this guy talking to me like
this but i accepted the criticism and
um
and i miss him a lot but uh yeah it's
there's
just doing the right thing you've got to
do the right thing we all are born with
good hearts
i mean everybody is born with a great
heart and the people that i see on this
channel
you know there's so many people that
you know they're they're lost they they
or they were or they're finding their
way or from a drug addiction to rehab to
relapses and etc
um one thing that none of the people on
this soft white underbelly
realize is that
your heart is still good no matter how
much you damage it
and we're all born with good hearts and
we should take advantage of that
and so that's
what drives me
right
has technology made life better for us
or
is it undermining our ability to find
happiness
that's a great question
it's sort of both right as
as clearly now we're able to film
hollywood's
cinematography type interviews
in any location
but and communi and call anyone
the communications
um
they're so advanced and so unbelievable
even from 30 years ago 20 years ago
i
i still marvel being able to
walk around with my flip phone and make
a call to someone in tokyo
um
the
the the darks that
the dark side of technology
has
always been there and
it's making things worse because
you have
websites like
[Music]
twitter and facebook and
myspace and all of these ridiculous
things that people share all of their
information with
and that's reshaping the foundation of
who we are as a species
such as take for instance now you have
people that simply type in shorthand
because they've never
written a letter with a pin
there are
so many disastrous consequences to come
you have the ideas and expectations of
the metaverse which i hate saying
and the web 3 or web 4
the in the engaging
future of
social engagement in an avatar based
fantasy
reality that
already is present
with
cryptocurrencies and non-fungible tokens
being the basis of these technologies
and
i feel that
these social technologies as they become
more ingrained will dissolve our desire
to
wishing to touch one another
as it already does now
just
look at people who
date on
apps
they have no emotion or feeling
basically because they've become numb to
seeing so many people that they have a
choice to
date or see
what happened to people touching each
other
and having an honest conversation
that's
that should be found again but
technology is going to prevent it every
step because someone has
a click or pay-per-view or a
an ad dollar or
something that's driving it or an or an
influence or
so the landscape changes as the more our
lives become dependent on technology
in a
pretty sinister way unfortunately
so it's safe to say that
social media
even though it's it's supposed to bring
us all together
it seems to be tearing us apart at the
same time absolutely ask any lawyer any
in any city anywhere in the world
yeah ask any ask any lawyer what the
number one reason that they are
handling a divorce and they will tell
you facebook the number one reason
the number one reason let that be
an indication of the things to come
people say oh well i'll use twitter or
i'll just anonymously use
tiktok or
these other silly services
they're entertaining and should not be
used for more than 10 minutes a day but
people spend hours and hours on these
things
yeah
when is the last time that you can find
someone under 30 years old that spent
most of their time outside and speaking
to other people rather than looking at a
glass slab
what's your prognosis for
mankind then with all this technology
that's exponentially growing
and progressing i believe there's a
great prognosis for mankind i don't
paint oblique picture outlook at all i
think
that
we are going to do just fine in the
future
once we get through some of these silly
road bumps that we experience now and in
the future technology will actually be
so
transparent within our lives it that it
will be
it will be
hard to imagine a life without it and so
we still
touch things like
cameras and phones and computer
keyboards and
when the technology becomes invisible
that's when things will become much much
better smartphone smart
the puck device
speaker things those are
these are all poor attempts at
that reality
things will be great
with anything we have our perils
look at internal combustion engines for
example
we
fully recognize that it's
they're bad for our planet but
we're just now
taking action on those
issues and so
it's good to see
that shift because
that was one of the
first indicators of how bad technology
treats us
was the invention of
technology that's polluted the planet so
far
so given that you're
as a hacker you're looking for
vulnerabilities constantly right right
that's what you do yes
does that bleed into your personal life
when you're interacting with somebody
you're you're seeing their
vulnerabilities
it does it certainly does and
it's it's an unfortunate consequence of
just me being who i am i
try not to but
i
readily notice things
in someone's presence whether it's the
114 slats in the door behind you or the
16 different
vents in this room
i count the i look for the risk
associated with any situation that i
encounter and
determine the threat and possibility of
either reduction or improvement
within a few seconds
[Music]
one of the one of the things that i i've
you know i i
i've always had a condition
to
where
it's
where where i see numbers where when
people are programming
in python or whatever
you see numbers and letters and
and
you see
syntax error
et cetera but i don't see any of that i
i don't see numbers
syntax or
brackets i
simply see colors
and those
those colors are
associated with everything that i
encounter including
people in real life and
online and so
um
it's uh
it's it's it is yes i
cannot escape the fact that i i'm a
hacker and it
that's who i am i i don't clock in at 9
00 a.m and turn it off at 5.
and so it's definitely in my personal
life it's
it's entered into my personal life um
in good and bad ways and
i uh
look to
avoid it as much as possible in my
personal life
even though you see how the evil exists
in the world and and is progressing you
still you're you remain an optimist
i do you're in the front lines of all
the evil that's being done or a lot of
it right
you know especially in technology and
things like that i am and i i believe
you know i
you know it's just like any belief
there
you know no one likes the police right
what's wrong with people if who are you
going to call when you're getting jumped
on
the police they're like
the police were
beat up because they
there's
bad police in cities that do bad things
well with any profession
[Music]
there's going to be bad apples and it's
so cliche to say but it's true
[Music]
the
the the
fact that
people aren't
using
their
common sense really is a strong
indicator of
what we know what we've learned and
where we're heading
and so that's
pretty much the summary of my feeling on
that
so you had very little education you
didn't go to college you didn't go to
you didn't graduate high school did you
i did not no i
um
um yourself you're a self-learner
i have i've
taught myself everything i
i dropped out in the
seventh grade
and um
i taught myself everything um by the
time that i dropped out of school
it was really boring for me
the teachers were very frustrated with
my approach to their curriculum
and rightly so i would have been
frustrated with someone who had
more knowledge than them and
most teachers then
and even now don't care they just wish
to obtain a paycheck
would that know i've never went to
college
high school i don't know what it feels
like to
date the prom queen or
or any of that you know when
when other kids were
you know
watching the cosby show and
you know laying in their warm beds you
know i i was
you know i was trying to figure out how
to
hack into something to provide me with
some comfort like you know is it an atm
is it a building or
am i swapping upc's at the market
but those were survival those things
that i you know i'm not happy that i did
all of that stuff
but
you have to do what you have to do to
survive and fortunately i
never had to
harm anyone which was never
a rule anyhow so
now over the past year i've taught at
jacksonville university i taught
intrusion detection systems
for a cyber security course over there
kind of ironic right i
now
have been asked to
teach at university and
and never having
left the eighth grade but
i now
speak to professors and
and thought leaders and
and ceos of companies and like i've
mentioned before very important and
powerful people
and it's interesting when i have
meetings with most of these people that
[Music]
my
my perception of their intelligence
sometimes sits on a balance
like a
like a teeter-totter
i've spoken at
several
universities over the past year as well
and
the year prior and i've
been working with the kids to
the college kids and
helping them
foresee a future in cyber security and
information technology and
the the the young the young minds
and it's been great it's been a great
fascinating
it's fascinating to walk through a
college campus and
wonder what it would have been like to
been there 30 years earlier
but
it's so it's it's interesting but uh
yeah i've taught myself everything that
i've needed to learn in life and
and uh
i i you know as a hacker you never stop
learning
i will never stop learning until i pass
away someone who says that they're going
to retire or
they're
they're just there to do a nine-to-five
job they are not
that's not
what they should be doing then they
should be doing something else
but
if you are driven by
a core belief like i am and for me there
are many
then you'll find great
joy and passion within anything that you
do whether it's
information technology cyber security or
being a brick mason
no one
no one judges you no one wants to judge
you
but everyone wants to be the main
character in the show
everybody
everywhere you look in society on all of
the internet you see will fight for you
or fighting for you or breaking news
this or
[Music]
who are who who are we fighting i mean
who
what you know lawyer and lawyer ads on
billboards and
will fight for you what what does that
mean like
does
what happened to we will litigate
properly we will litigate your case what
is why is fight and all of this
this anger i mean
i'm beside myself when i
am in public and look at like a
television screen they have a news feed
and
i see
people yelling and screaming at each
other and
you know back to you bob and you know
they yell and scream at for eight
minutes and then they go to a commercial
and then it's back to yelling and
screaming again with
no real constructive output or
resolution and
and
now we are at the throws of a madman
with nuclear weapons in europe and
if that's not the most scary thing about
someone having technology at their
disposal i don't know what is so
you want to know who has the best big
button with a chip in it it would be
that guy
[Music]
and
[Music]
my heart is with
everyone in europe
is capitalism or greed
the biggest problem that we we have and
there's such a wealth gap in our country
and it just seems like
the rich are getting richer and the poor
are getting poorer and it just
seems like it's just going to continue
that way no i i don't see it that way i
see the motivations coming from
misinformation from what we consume
everybody's got their face glued to
something
you have your favorite website
they have their favorite website they
have their favorite website
you
obtain your information from all of
these different
streams
[Music]
and once that information becomes
distorted
[Music]
then you become distorted i had
i had a man come up to me in a
restaurant and started
screaming at me about
[Music]
you know
political things and
it was frightening
and so
people
again
i
must have conversations go to your local
bar or dive or
park
and meet your neighbor i i bet
i bet anyone
that they don't even know four or five
of their neighbors that live around them
and most people don't even know their
next door neighbor
that's what's wrong it's not
we should fear this or
this government's not doing this for us
so we should ask for more and encourage
even more change to people who will
never enact it
we
we are
we are all unique with our own heart
it's easy to have a conversation
try it
it's not hard to do
and gomo what would you say is the most
important thing all of this has taught
you
it's it's taught me to
share these experience that i speak of
now for the second time
most likely the last
i i
i i have read the words that people have
written to me in response to the first
video that i recorded with you
and
and it's
overwhelming
and
heartwarming to know that
[Music]
i've been validated
and so everybody that's
believed in me
yeah
it
everybody on your channel has
shown me that love
and uh
you know that's all that's all i'm about
man is you know just
making sure that we use our hearts
for something this is we use our hearts
for something good we don't
we don't
we're only here for such a short time
and people argue and fight and panic and
just
find
find your heart like i found mine
[Music]
and once you do right you will
realize the things that you've done
aggressively
in all your life have been wrong
[Music]
my only regret is i wish i had more time
to and i wish i had
found my heart sooner
to share the things that i know now and
so
i'll keep doing that
um
and i want people to do that as well
excellent come on thank you so much for
coming back and sharing more of your
wisdom with us
thank you mark it's my last time for
sure
thank you very much thank you
you